[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys good morning here from Japan
now I'm gonna meet up with a few friends
we're gonna have some sushi from a real
master chef so I'm just super excited
we're gonna show you guys how you should
eat sushi the right way we're gonna show
you a few other stuff as well but let's
get to it
[Music]
EEE
ee-ee-ee-ee
alright guys finally here with my
friends we're gonna go to the
traditional sushi place
but first hope you guys just introduce
yourself first under ok so hi I'm Andrea
Coco here I I'm half Italian half
Japanese I'm an Italian actor
[Music]
and today I'm gonna bring Anton and
Daniel to stand butchy that it this it's
this traditional Japanese place and hope
you're gonna enjoy it
yeah yeah hi I'm Anton Erin's German
model 20 years old and it's my first
time being out here in Japan yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we are here with the owner we're here
with the owner of San pushy he's a
master chef Saint patty Hanukkah bush
must go go it's more ivy I told on you
must go good oh my god she must so he
introduced himself he said his name and
he said welcome to everybody to my place
and so it's pretty much all right
let's have some sushi yes all right guys
finally we're here at the traditional
sushi place and I'm gonna ask you my
friend just to explain everything here
because I have no clue so okay so we are
at the san poachy
it means eight votes this is the
traditional sushi sushi place our sushi
master is Nina cutting yeah without even
looking
[Music]
there's a different things to know about
when you go inside a sushi place first
of all when you order to drink if you
don't take for them it's normal to give
you the classical medially so this is a
raw fish with with rice if in case
instead you order alcohol normally they
give you only sashimi so basically just
a raw fish
because basically alcohol that before
was only sacked as substitutes the rice
yes slightly it's making our nice
just very quickly guys for you guys what
is normal sushi sometimes fusion sushi
and maybe you can just talk a little bit
and just say what is the difference
between fusion sushi when we get in the
Western right yeah well and real sushi
yes there's there's many differences
obviously the ingredients like for
example in traditional sushi there's no
avocado because there's no other
catalyst in Japan no I knew it it's
things that come afterwards with global
market and everything you start to mix
things that's why it's called future not
in that sense and you saw a lot of
Japanese immigrants for example in
Brazil or in the States and then two
different things like for example the
monkey doesn't exist in Japan it's in a
mention that comes from abroad and for
example yeah yes so so would you say
that traditional of real sushi is mainly
a nigiri the rice will never start be
gorgeous or just the raw fish only okay
my sister yes sashimi and Maki this is
the traditional way
so sushi is one of the few things that
you can eat with your hands
in Japan alright so not with the
chopsticks you can also the chopsticks
but the important thing is when you have
this plate and put your soy sauce
normally in the need is already like the
Bobby wasabi is just a little bit it has
too intense the cleaner fish so you put
it you take it with your hands like this
and you have to put the fish on the soy
sauce not the rice and then use it
[Music]
so say again with the city the seaweed
see we have this in this pine is like
kind of an appetizer yes we take some
you you dip it in this sauce that's
baseball soy sauce always but it's less
strong as a table a little bit more acid
because it has also lemon all right and
it's very good for your health actually
he everyday goes to the fish market to
buy different kind of fish that he
thinks his clients might his guests
might enjoy so every day is different
it's not always this a nice and a super
fresh yes it has to be otherwise it can
be dangerous right a great thing for
example a difference behind a Capitan
have Japanese so in Italy for example
normally the sallman
it's very fatty because it's not wild
here instead they always have only the
well one and so it's only orange you
don't have later big white stripes
I see if you notice yeah yeah when you
have like these big white stripes
normally it's because it's taking care
by humans oh you guys hear that yes so
yeah we have today I can see sea bass
tuna it's right you'll see it on the
camera ok so when we start to eat sushi
right yeah I'm just a few rules yeah
when you do it with the the chopsticks
yes
is it rude to put it dumps in certain
ways or not well it's not rude like they
have normally it's not here but they
have something where you can lay down
the the chopsticks the only thing you
never have to do
these chopsticks it's still like put
them inside the rice Oh in yep because
that meant in the past meant that
somebody died in your Oh oh yeah
so they normally did that so don't stick
your chopsticks in the rice yeah then
leave it there like this damn it ever so
now he just brought us this meat and in
this case it's from squid all right and
I'm even here and you just take it and
put it boys
all right so fish first
[Music]
very nice you see how in the traditional
place smell like the fish is a lot the
rice looks so much you see how the rice
that's just made you know it's not cold
it's just in the right temperature all
right so just a few things I've noticed
already in South Africa we use a lot of
soya sauce or I've seen a lot of people
do it right but that's wrong in a way it
doesn't have to look like a pool because
soy sauce is like our salt okay so it
you it's used in the same way as our
alright so I don't think we put like
tons of salt and I'll flavor so in this
same way we have to use soy sauce sushi
you just dip it a little bit and then
you taste it obviously depends by your
what you like if you like very salty
food then you just you know and it's
funny I normally just put a little bit
light bowls of ice before wasabi you
just put like a little bit because most
of it enhances oh yes the flavor I know
there's always people that like spicy
taste and then they just go like let me
start to cry because it gives you that
kick yeah yeah I normally did go for
that alright alright so there's this
three things you basically eat with your
sushi right it's the wasabi
is the soil sauce and then we have also
the ginger the Ranger so the ginger let
me ask you a question about the ginger
yeah what is it supposed to be used for
and how she means now ginger for example
in Italy they do a big mistake the
ginger as if it's like chips like
non-stop but instead it has the same
purpose as to two places like for
example we just ate now some tuna let me
take some ginger
it's like washes your mouth and then you
can go and eat squid so that the flavors
don't mix now here he just gave us also
some for my vote basically egg done in
the Japanese way normally it says - they
normally say that they make it as if
it's like layers of the Japanese sword
thousands of players ok it's a technique
oh we are making the vegan layers and
with also a little bit sugar so I got
inside in this case you can use your
chopsticks you eat a little bit you can
eat it like this
their egg or you can just put it a
little bit in the soy sauce too much
Antone got wasabi alright so I'm gonna
take you about it
[Music]
so to Touro right yeah let's try
together it's between fatty and not in
the way so you have these three kinds
thought of the most packaged sugar in
between as fatness and then mangu oh
it's a typical only red tuna with no
fast in explanation this is Marco maguro
yeah it's the non fatty tuna good the
texture it doesn't even fuel its fish
there's a little bit of a sabi here yeah
so you guys don't always have to add
with something to it it already has
[Music]
these are quail eggs and from here they
eat them like obviously wrong pic with
the normal inside one con algún con is
just rice with a round seaweed I never
had this before so there's gonna be
interesting for sure as soon as I'm now
we're having our gunk on that was
telling you about before it's a bigger
piece of rice with around seaweed and
play like this you have to put inside
the soy sauce obviously okay from the
bottom not from the top because offering
other way that the egg that comes out
they need it
[Music]
he's saying that you're gonna get strong
hey it's like a natural Niagara alright
alright guys it's super good I love this
Oh indeed totally also eat raw eggs so I
don't know if you're used to it yeah I
mean it's like the average awesome isn't
this time is the same thing but also
with Salman eggs some and eggs yes ikura
it's all now it's particular cause in
Japanese they call it ikura salmon eggs
but actually the original the word is
Russian I do wrong in this case - you
put a lot of soy sauce and then you
eaten
[Music]
now we're getting how maybe I might be
Nigri so this is basically rock shrimp
oh that's really sweet potato and straw
there's three on there yes yes
the tail Antonis eating in the german
way but in the german way like a
thousand years ago
[Music]
always nice palutena grasses but in this
case with the onion face there is a
different enhancement and then you
always put it in
[Music]
so this is normal suckin cold only you
keep it like that yes everything you
wanna go mmm that's a European thing of
drinking all in one go if I have to make
my Japanese friends really drunk I'd do
that good different posthumous head so
in this case this is one of my favorite
things actually now this is like cooked
fatty tuna with poor rose water I don't
know how to call it but it's kind of an
onion and a vegetable okay when you
touch it you feel like it as if you're
eating meat Wow it's it's really really
amazing this try go ahead so you just
take it yeah you eat it yes for us it's
doing
[Music]
alright guys this is been amazing now
you know a little bit more about how to
eat sushi the right way thank you guys
so much for sharing this with us sushi
chef thank you very much oh my gosh I'm
us you know modeling is a lot of fun
when you traveling experience different
cultures and people and countries and it
is really a lot of fun but it comes a
time when you just miss home you missed
us unique things from home so for me
from South Africa it's been five months
since I since I've seen my wife and my
dog and my family and it is time to go
home
so I'm packed I'm ready to go solicitor
[Music]
falls down and you have taken all you
care to do
[Music]
[Music]
and the tears in our eyes tear the
traces it
until
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]